We're here to talk about
media playback the right way,
so we're really going to kind of
go through all of the different
components and different
system things that you need
to actually integrate
with if you really want
a top-of-the-line
media playback.
So a little bit about me, I've
been doing Android development
for just about five years now.
Started kind of on my
own in my spare time,
got caught up in part
of my master's degree,
and then transitioned
to doing it full time.
First at Phunware
and then at Facebook.
I'm sorry I didn't fix
everything I wanted to.
[LAUGHTER]
There's a lot more
I wanted to fix.
But this last year, I've been
working as a developer advocate
at Google, so talking to the
community and kind of bringing
a lot of your feedback back to
the engineering teams as well.
I've been working on two
major projects since then.
We did an advanced Android class
for Udacity, so kind of online
learning going a little bit
deeper into App architecture.
And then, as well,
just recently launched
Android development
patterns, a video series
as well as pro tips around
kind of all of the things
that really are the best
practices for Android
development.
And my focus has generally
been on the Android framework
and the Android support
library, which both of which
play very nicely into this.
Now when we talk about media
playback there's actually
like tons of levels
and many things
we could talk about
here, and we're really
going to talk about just
one part, specifically
audio playback.
Now it's important to note that
if you're doing video playback,
almost all of this still
applies to you, right?
The interactions with the
system and that type of stuff
still matter if
you're doing video.
But video is a little bit
of a head start on us.
The actual cast companion
library, it's out.
It's something our team actually
supports and keeps up to date.
But it encapsulates a lot of
the best practices around video
and integrating with things
like Google Cast as well,
so you kind of get that
full multi-room experience.
So let's start at the
beginning, and the beginning
should always be with the user.
They're kind of the most
important part in actually
making our apps useful
pieces of information,
and when we think
about that, we really
want to think about what
the user's expecting.
When they're going into your
app, what you don't want
them is to be surprised
in a negative way.
But you want those
positive surprises
like, oh, I didn't know
the app could do that.
Or like, oh, well, it's
actually doing everything
I expect, and it's
doing it great,
and that's where we want
our media apps to be,
not in meeting expectations, but
really exceeding expectations.
And of course for
an audio app, you
can't really do that without
background playback, right?
There's literally no audio
app you'll find out there
that forces you to keep the
activity open the entire time
you're playing audio.
It just doesn't work very well
on Android, especially when you
consider phone calls another
interruptions like that.
So we really need to
get the basics down
before we can
exceed expectations.
Now when you think
background playback, that
should immediately
ring bells like,
oh, maybe a service
makes lot of sense.
They're specifically
designed for doing
that kind of background work
not tied to any UI piece.
Now when it comes
to media playback
in a service, what
kind of things
are we actually doing
in that service,
so naturally, every service
is created at some point.
That is what kind of
kicks off the process.
That's our one-time feedback
or one time initialization
kind of step.
And then for most media
apps, you kind of have two,
I would say, top level states.
You have playing, which I'll
use as a shorthand for audio
is actually coming
out of the device.
And then you have
paused, which is
kind of all those other
states, whether they're
buffering or actually paused,
where audio is not being played
but is in a state where
these may want to transition
back to playing.
Similarly, stopped is kind
of the final state, right?
When the user says,
I'm done with your app.
I've moved on.
Maybe I've opened up another
media app, et cetera.
And then of course
services hopefully
eventually get
destroyed, and this
is where we'll reclaim
our final memory
and get back to kind of a
steady state of our app is not
running.
So it wouldn't be
much of an audio app
if we didn't
actually play audio.
On Android, we have a media
player which does exactly that.
It's really good at
playing audio tracks,
but it's maybe not the most
customizable thing of all time.
We do have ExoPlayer, which
is another player that's
supported on higher API
levels that you can use if you
need more control over here.
But for the whole rest of this
talk, everything I talk about
will be player agnostic, so
whether you're doing something
that specifically requires media
player or ExoPlayer should all
fit in the framework
of everything else
we're going to talk about.
So how do our events,
that we just talked about,
map to, say, media player?
So it's actually really
straightforward, right?
We're going to create
a new media player,
and then when we're
playing, we'll
prepare and then play the
track, pause, pause, stop, stop.
And then when we're
finally destroyed,
we'll release all of
our service, right?
This super-straightforward
creating and getting everything
done, and we're done.
All right, lots of time
back we're playing audio,
but the problem is that just
playing audio in the background
is probably a detriment to
users rather than a positive.
We've given them no
controls over it,
and other apps are now
trying to interact with them.
And really we're in kind
of a net negative kind
of perspective.
But what we actually want
to do is go a lot farther,
and that actually means that d
we need to do a few more things
to actually get us to play
nicely with the rest system,
be a good citizen on Android,
and really be the best app
we can be.
So the first thing here is
going to be audio focus.
Now audio focus is kind
of this key in Android
of being that good
citizen, right?
It's that concept that your
app is going to play audio,
and that is your consideration
of being the audio focus.
But that doesn't mean that
you can ignore every other app
on the system, every
notification beep that
comes in, other player
starting, maps navigation
is a really good
example of this.
We really want to be
considerate of those other apps
when you're doing
audio playback.
Now this is slightly distinct
from actually playing audio.
We'll actually still want to use
audio focus when we're paused
or in that kind of
intermediate state
because if another player were
to start playing while we're
buffering, for
example, we still don't
want to talk over that other
app when we're actually
ready to play.
So some code actually
registering our audio focus,
and we can see here, we'll
use audio manager for this.
It's kind of the core for doing
this core audio kind of work,
and then we'll call
request audio focus.
In this case, we'll
pass in a special
on stream listener,
which is where we'll
get these callbacks
back, and we'll
talk about that momentarily.
And then we'll want to say
we're streaming music or media,
and then we're
going to say, we're
going to game audio focus.
Now in almost all cases,
you'll get granted back.
The system will say, oh, great
you are requesting audio focus.
You are a nice app.
I like you, and you
get audio focus.
Now there are some
examples where
you won't get audio focus.
For example, if the user
is currently in a phone,
you won't get audio
focus in that sense
because they're actively
talking in a call.
And you'll want to wait until
the actual phone call is done
and then do the call
from there, or have
the user repress
the Play button when
they're done with their phone.
So what does that focus
change actually give us ?
Well, it's really kind of
that key between our app
and all the other
apps on the system,
where we get all
that information.
So for example, you may get
an audio focus loss symbol.
Now this is kind of that
permanent loss of focus.
At this point, they've said,
well, the user has moved on.
Another app has said, I
want to gain focus forever,
and it's not coming back.
It's just not coming
back, so in this case,
you probably just
want to stop playback.
You say, all right,
I will gracefully
exit stage and allow the other
app, which has requested focus,
to continue on.
Now, one thing you
might consider here
is if the user accidentally hit
the Play button another app.
Instead of immediately stopping,
you may pause, wait 30 seconds,
and then stop.
That's certainly
a active pattern
if you want to prevent some
of those false negatives.
Now another one
that they can use
if someone is using gain
transient, in this case,
the other app is asking for
you to stop temporarily.
So in this case, you probably
just want to pause the playback
and wait for them to finish
there 15 seconds or whatever.
So you may take this is an
example of someone saying
something out loud or say
you're on a running app,
and the running is saying
like your splits and pace.
And maybe they don't want
to talk over your other app.
They just want you to
pause for a second,
and then you'll come back.
Now the last transit one is
actually called can duck,
and we've talked
about ducking earlier.
This is a different ducking.
This is actual can ducking, and
that really just means lowering
the volume temporarily.
So in this case,
this is what, say,
notifications use when
you get a notification in.
Instead of the music
completely stopping,
it'll just lower in volume.
You hear the chime, and
then it'll come back up,
and it comes back up when
you get an audio focus game,
so this is when you've
returned from any
of those transient losses.
Now one thing to note
about the can duck
is that it doesn't mean you
have to lower the volume.
If you're doing, say, a
podcast player or something
with spoken words where
it's really important
you get every word.
Or else if your
talking for 10 seconds
while there's another
sound going on,
that's not going to
be very intelligible.
So you can certainly
pause or do whatever
you need to do in that
can duck scenario.
You don't have to
just lower the volume.
So our updated life
cycle, we're playing,
or pausing, we're
stopping, were docking.
Well, lots of -ings.
But you can see we've kind
of filled in a new row
here where as soon as we start
playing for that first time,
we've gone along that
request audio focus
and then start our
playback once we've
received that granted playback.
And then when they've
actually stopped
and we're done playing
audio entirely,
we'll want to
abandon audio focus.
And so that already makes
us a lot better part
of the overall system.
We're no longer going to
be talking over other apps.
It's great, but it's
not all we can do.
Actually one of my favorite
broadcasts of all time
is the becoming noisy
or the noisy broadcast.
So this is actually when, say,
you're listening on headphones
and that type of thing, and
then your speaker comes out
and all of a sudden, you're
blaring to the whole audience.
And we can't really control
what our tastes in music
are for our users, but
we can prevent them
from some embarrassing
situations on that case
by registering just a simple
broadcast receiver that
listens for that
becoming noisy intent
and then pauses our music.
So in this case,
we're going to want
to tie this to the life cycle
of actually playing audio.
There's no reason to listen
for being noisy if you are not
being noisy.
So we'll register when we
actually start playback right
after we get audio focus.
And then actually unregister
as soon as we pause playback.
So in this case,
it's really more
of that a little bit of
connection in there to say,
like OK, well, I really
don't want the user
to get into this bad scenario.
So out of it, register,
unregister, easy, done, OK.
Now at this point, were actually
fairly well off ' an audio
perspective.
We're not going to
be playing audio,
and we're not supposed
to be playing audio.
But there's a lot more we
can do to be an amazing app.
Another part of it
is really that sense
of controlling
audio playback, that
reaching for the next track
button or the pause button.
These are the kind of
things that people are going
to use your app and do a lot.
And we don't want to make
that really tricky to use.
We actually want to make it
as easy as possible for users
to get in control of
your media playback.
And thankfully,
there's a lot of ways
to do that in the
Android framework.
One of the first ones
that you might think of
are headphones and
Bluetooth controls.
Now for me personally, this is
probably the most frustrating
one when apps don't
do it correctly.
When you're in your car, and
you have integrated Bluetooth
controls, those are the kind of
scenarios that users should not
ever have to go into your
app to find the pause button
or hit the Play button
or anything like that.
Instead, you should be
handling these in your app.
Now we generally
call these headphone
and Bluetooth controls,
collectively, media buttons.
So in fact, they're
actually just
like any other keyboard event
from Android's point of view.
You've got to key
down when someone
depresses the
button and then key
up when they release the button.
Now by default, the
system is actually
going to send out a
broadcast whenever
it gets one of these messages
using the aptly-named media
button intent.
And this intent
actually includes
the key event of the down
or up and what action
was actually hit.
So in that sense, we
can create our own,
but in the support library
in the brand new 23.1 release
that came out a
few days ago now,
we've actually created a
media button receiver which
does exactly this for you.
Now one of the problems with cut
this kind of broadcast receiver
is, because it's a broadcast
receiver in your manifest,
somehow you need to
get that information
into your actual service that
we've been talking about,
right?
You can't necessarily play
from the broadcast receiver
when it's the service.
How do you do all
that communication?
And that's what media button
receiver actually does for you.
So how do you set up a
media button receiver?
You just registered
it in your manifest.
It's a simple
receiver, UCR media
button intent filter here
notice that you haven't
written any code at all.
But what it'll do is when it
finds a service which also has
the Media button
intent filter, it'll
automatically pass
any intents that
are received such as those
media buttons onto your service.
And now the service can actually
handle those play and pause
and toggle play controls
in its on start command.
No longer you have to
write this communication
layer between your
broadcast receiver
and your service to
get through everything.
There's one problem though.
If you write this,
it won't work at all.
So why is that?
We wrote media button receiver.
It should just work.
It turns out that sending
a broadcast to every media
app on your device,
not a good idea.
You don't want to
see what happens
when you hit play on 10
different media players
all at the same time.
It's not pretty.
Thankfully audio focus
handles most of it,
but it will look funny,
so instead, the system
has this concept of a preferred
media button receiver.
It's basically a last
wins kind of a model,
so the last one to register that
they want to be the preferred
media button wins.
Very similar to kind of
the audio focus model,
where as you're the last one
to say I want audio focus,
you get it.
So if you've ever had Play Music
respond to a Bluetooth control
when you're, in fact,
listening to another app,
that's because something's
messed up in the preferred
media button receiver.
So that is one of many things
that media session compat
gives you.
Now MediaSessionCompat
does a lot.
It's actually based on a
lollipop addition called
media session, funnily
enough, and it's
our entry point
between our media app
and all of the
media framework API,
so all the things we're
going to talk about here
shortly are all kind of
tied into this one object.
Now the nice part
is that this object,
even though it was
built in API 21,
auto translates to older API.
So if you ever use
remote control receiver
and other things
we won't mention,
those deprecated APIs, you
don't have to use them.
[INAUDIBLE] will automatically
do the right thing for you.
Now first we'll want to
create our media session.
We'll create it in our
service pretty much as soon
as our services is created
just like our media player
that we'll create
as soon as possible.
Passing in a logging
tag, so anything
goes wrong it's very
easy to actually debug
where in the steps
actually fell apart.
And then you'll want
to set two flags.
One that we actually
want to handle
our media buttons and the second
one is transport controls.
These are play and pause type of
controls from within your app.
Basically just always
want to set them.
I'm not sure why they're
not the defaults.
And then the last thing
is setting that callback.
Now the callbacks are
actually really important.
That's where you get on
play on pause on stop.
It's basically that central
entry point between where
all the media APIs
are going to go
and your actual media player.
So the onplay method of
here would cause play
on your media player.
So we haven't actually set that
we want to be the preferred
media button.
Thankfully it's one method.
It's that setActive that you
can guess what the Boolean does.
True means we want to become the
active media button receiver.
False means we're
done, and we can leave.
So it actually does a lot
behind the backgrounds,
but one of things it does
is the Media button intent.
Now once we have this media
session combat set up,
we can actually take
advantage of the other part
of media button receiver which
is its handle intent method.
Handle intent
method, which you can
put in your on start command,
automatically translates
all the key events,
extracts them
from the intents,
does all that work,
and just hand them
off to your callbacks.
So now you don't need to do
that translation of, all right,
well, this is a key
down of toggle play,
and then that translates
to an on play command.
You just pass it
on through and keep
using the call backs that
you've defined as part
of media session compat.
Now how does media
session know anything
about what toggle
play should do?
We haven't actually told
it if we're playing or not.
That's what media
state compat is for.
So you can think of
media state compat
as kind of all of the
information about what
your app is currently doing.
So while you may,
within your app,
are we playing, are we
pausing, are we buffering,
the system knows nothing.
You haven't told it
anything, so we'll
have to do exactly
that using set state.
Now set state is kind
of the playing paused.
It actually looks like an enum
but is, in fact, not an enum.
It's just ints.
And we'll also want to
include our position, so
how far along we
are in the track,
if that's applicable to you.
And then we also
have set actions,
so set actions are things
like do I support play pause?
Do I support stop?
Do I support next track?
Not every player supports
going to the previous track.
You really want to make
sure that you actually
put all of the things you
support because this is what's
going to show up
on various surfaces
such as the lock screen later.
And it's also how media
buttons get filtered out.
If you say you
don't support pause,
and someone clicks the
button on their head phone,
you won't get it an on-pause
playback or callback.
So really make sure
that you're actually
also setting the actions.
Now you'll note
that both of these
are combined into the same
playback state compat.
It turns out that
in most media apps,
these are actually
tied together.
While you're
buffering, you probably
don't have a pause action.
When your buffering,
you probably
don't have a skip to
next, but you may still
want to support a stop command
to be able to stop things
if it's really
buffering on forever,
so they are kind of combined
together under the assumption
that you'll probably change
both of them at the same time.
So probably one of my favorite
features in Ice Cream Sandwich
are lock screen
controls, so kind
of that play pause,
pretty album art, probably
the best feature besides
the whole combining phones
and tablets and all that.
It's fine.
Lock screen controls,
definitely the best.
Now they're actually
fairly easy to add.
The only thing we're been
missing so far because we
already set our actions is
actually just some metadata
including a picture.
We can't really show
anything on the screen
if we're not showing
that type of thing.
So and that's where media
metadata compat comes in.
Again, we'll just
kind of set it in.
You can kind of think of it as
a bundle of all the information
about what's currently playing.
Now note, this is actually
used in more places
than just the lock screen.
So if you've ever
noticed, on Android Wear
you get a little notification
of playing audio and stuff.
It's actually using the
metadata you pass in,
that album art, all
that information is
coming from the media
metadata use set.
So what kind of
information goes in here?
A lot of the basics,
title, artist, album,
all kind of really
important ones.
If you are using
fixed duration tracks,
you probably want
to add the duration
it goes really well with
that position we already set.
On the image size, you
have add bitmaps directly.
Please do not add any like
4,000 by 4,000 giant bitmaps.
That's kind of the case
where URIs come in,
where you can actually pass a
URI to just a larger image that
then can be downloaded later.
Ideally, these should
be content URIs
so that other apps
can read from them.
I have a storage
talk tomorrow that
talks all about how you can
actually set up these URIs real
easy, but these are just some
of the most important ones.
There's actually like
27 of them in total, so
read through the documentation.
These are probably the ones
I'd recommend off the top.
So we've added our
media session compat.
Just a few more
steps along the way
we did our created setting
the flags, playing,
we'll want to set active
to true, set our metadata,
set our state.
Similarly, anytime we pause
or buffer or change anything
really, want to make
sure our state stays
in sync with our app as well
as then when we're actually
stopped, we'll set active to
false and say, hey, we're done.
And then release,
went around destroyed
to return all those resources.
Now I talked about
locks and controls.
They're really great, but we
kind of removed them from 5.0.
It turns out that notifications
are the new hotness
and are kind of what
the lock screen is
all about now as of Lollipop.
Now it turns out we
probably should have been
using notifications all along.
The fact of having to lock
your device just to use a play
pause button, probably
a little silly.
So notifications
kind of give you
that access anywhere--
anywhere in any app
you can pull down the
notification tray and play
and pause on that type of thing.
But building that
custom notification can
be a lot more complicated
than you want,
so we built it all for you.
We have a notification
compat media style,
so this style kind
of automatically
allows you to add media
buttons without having
to create giant custom
notifications every time, so
unless an API 14.
In fact, you couldn't add any
buttons to a notification.
Like there was a time when
all a notification was just
a single tap target.
It was like years ago, but
we still support it here.
You'll get just a basic
notification that allows
someone to click into your app.
Starting in API 14, you
can actually have buttons.
So you support buttons in
that single line state.
You can have up to three
buttons right there
in the notification.
API 16 Android 4.1
added expanded controls,
so here you'll get a
larger image for album art,
and you'll get up
to five controls.
And in Lollipop, we
actually switch over
to the framework media style.
So basically from there
on out, you'll actually
have the exact styling
across every device,
and it'll look just
like any system one.
Now one thing to note is that
all of this notification compat
is in app compat,
not necessarily
in the support
before, which is where
all of the rest of the
notification compat stuff
is, so just keep aware of that.
Now I like writing
boilerplate code once.
I never want you to
write boilerplate code.
So I've come up with kind of
a media style helper class
which kind of does a
lot of the building,
taking in a media session
and then building out
a notification compat for you.
So we can actually extract
a lot of information
if we've set our media metadata.
In fact, media metadata
has a very nice method
called get description,
which kind of extracts
the most important information,
those information that we
called out earlier such
as title and artist,
and actually allows us to build
our whole notification directly
from that, getting title,
get our description,
doing all this work
for so you don't have
to do this boilerplate work.
In fact, we can actually
pull out a session activity
if you've set it via media
session compact session
activity to launch your
activity automatically.
Now on 5.0 plus,
you can't actually
hide notification contacts
on the lock screen,
but generally we
actually do want
to show media controls
on the lock screen even
in those cases, so we
can set it as public.
Now you'll note here for
the delete intent, which
is when a notification
is swiped away,
we're actually using a
separate helper called
get action intent which
you'll pass in a key event,
and then it'll automatically
create the pending
intent for you.
Thankfully that's another
easy method that I created
and both of these
methods are just
on GitHub, which means you don't
have to write it ever again.
It's fantastic.
So we can actually just stick
with something very simple.
In fact, when you create
it from our notification,
and then we'll want to
set kind of the small icon
that appears on the top,
and then set the color.
Now color works a little bit
different for media style
notifications.
If you've ever seen a
notification on 5.0 plus,
the small icon,
the app icon, can
be colorized in the background.
You'll see a lot of
Google Apps do this.
In media sound of
cations it actually
is the whole background of
the entire notification,
so if you're using
bright orange,
I want to stab your eyes out.
[LAUGHTER]
Don't use bright
orange or any color
that really you want to
test it out and make sure
that the color
that you're setting
makes sense with your
actual color pallet
and doesn't look
ridiculous because it
has a strong chance
of looking ridiculous.
Now media styles wouldn't
really be much of anything
without actions.
So here I'm adding
a pause action
using our get action intent.
And then our style actually
just uses two methods,
one called this set show
actions in compact view.
So this is what sets
what actions appear
in that single line view.
By default, none
will, so you probably
want to set some zero index
array of what buttons to have.
So if you want the second
button you've added,
you'd add button one.
If you want the second and
third, one and two, et cetera.
And then the last part,
which is super critical,
but if you forget it people
will hate you, is media session,
so the set media
session is actually
what allows your notification
to work on Android Wear.
If you don't set
this then you'll
get a beautiful
notification on [INAUDIBLE],
and then you hit the pause
button and nothing happens.
It's the worst
feeling in the world.
We're like, oh, wow, that looks
amazing and nothing happens.
But what it's
actually doing is it's
using a session
token, so it's kind
of the unique identifier
for your session
and passing that on to
apps like Android Wear
such that they can
control your audio
and give you call
backs in your callback.
So we've added our notification.
Want to show it as soon
as we start playing,
but we want to update it
any time the states changed.
And then of course, remove
it when we've stopped
and we're all done.
But we've talked notifications.
Now turns out that there's
this concept called
foreground services
which kind of
raise our background services
priority to a higher level such
that it won't get killed.
Now foreground services
require a notification,
which thankfully we just
built. So we can actually
take advantage of this
for our media service.
Now it's actually
really important
because we really don't
want our service, which
is playing audio, to die
in the middle of things
just because someone
launches chrome
and it takes up all the
resources on your Android
device.
Believe me, they're
working on it.
[LAUGHTER]
But what we want is we want our
service because it is actively
playing music to live
just a little bit longer
and hopefully survive forever.
There's one caveat though.
Once you've started
a notification
with start foreground,
pre-Lollipop
it was ongoing forever.
You could never
swipe it away, which
was actually super frustrating.
So we fixed it, but it actually
affects media notifications
the most because if
you think about it,
you're going from a
foreground, I'm playing audio
to being paused not
foreground, very often,
and you don't want
your notification being
completely removed and re-put in
because it looks really janky.
So our media style
actually gives us
two methods which allow
you to kind of work around
that setting a cancel intent,
and basically this just adds
a little x in the
corner of your media
notification which allows
them even if they are ongoing
forever and you're
annoying users to no end,
they can just hit the x and
close out your notification.
In this case, we'll
set the intent
to just be a media stop just
like it got swiped away,
so it always is the
same whether it's
pre-Lollipop or post-Lollipop.
Nicely enough, on Lollipop
these methods just
don't do anything because it
doesn't apply on those levels.
You'll be able to swipe
it away as soon as you
say stop foreground false.
So stop foreground
false means I don't
want to be a foreground
service anymore, but keep
my notification up there.
I'm still alive, but
I don't necessarily
have the requirement to be at
the top of the priority list.
If your music is paused
forever, users probably
won't notice if it actually
gets destroyed or not.
And if you're really
under memory pressure,
it is kind of important to be
able to have Android clean up
your service.
So we've actually
done a whole lot.
We're playing.
We're pausing.
We're stopping.
We're not stepping
on other apps.
Bluetooth controls, work
lock screens, media controls
and notifications,
Android Wear, and we're
reliable under memory pressure.
That's pretty good.
Now we just forgot
one little thing,
you have an app that has
UI, that has controls,
and we haven't talked at
all about how that service
interacts with your actual UI.
Now you could be doing
something super simple
and saying just start
service with custom actions,
but it doesn't get you the
two-way communication you want.
You want so that when
the service switches
to the next song,
your UI stays in sync.
And ideally, we'd
want to actually reuse
those call backs we were using
so that when someone hits play
or pause in your UI, your
callbacks you've already set up
for media buttons
are automatically
handling those things.
Sounds pretty amazing right, so
we've built a class for that.
We've built a lot of classes.
Media controller compat kind
of does all that for you.
Once you've connected
to it, then you'll
actually get access to all
of the metadata you've set,
so you can tell what the
current playing track is.
All of the state, so you
can tell if you're playing
or paused and what position
you are as well as transport
controls, so these are
the methods of like play,
pause, skip to next, right,
kind of useful things to have,
and these pipe directly
into your callbacks.
There's no extra layers
you need to build,
no callback craziness.
It's just already built for you
in part of transport controls.
And because no one likes
pulling for media changes,
you actually get a
set of clawbacks.
So these callbacks
are the things
that's say like, oh, the
media metadata has changed.
We've switched to
the next track.
Oh, we went to buffering.
Instead of having
to pull your service
or have your service
send notifications
every time, whenever you
call set state or set
metadata, which
we're already doing,
then our callback will instantly
get a callback saying like,
hey, the metadata has changed.
You should update the UI
to match the new metadata.
All a sudden our
UI is now totally
in sync with our
service without us
having to write any
crazy communication
code between our
service and our UI
because we're using
media controller compat.
There is one wrinkle though.
That token that we need,
that media session token
that we pass through
out notification
is actually also what's needed
for media controller compat.
But person who knows about
our token is our service.
We somehow need to
get that to our UI.
Now [AUDIO OUT] really matter
how you get it to your UI,
but we do have a second
set of classes called
MediaBrowserService
and MediaBrowser, which
were introduced
in API 21 which do
all this connecting and
passing the session for you.
Nicely enough,
you don't actually
need a token to connect to
a media browser service,
and you'll get access to
actually new APIs as well such
as being able to browse
media items entirely.
This allows you to
actually build your UI off
of the information that's
already in the service.
For example, you could
have a list of tracks
and that would match
what's in your UI,
and you wouldn't have to create
a separate data store for that.
You can use the media browser
service and MediaBrowser
to connect to it.
Note this is also how all the
Android Wear or Android Auto
integration works,
so Android Auto
is actually connecting to
your media brother service
and then building the
whole UI, all the controls,
all of the information, from
the data you pass back to it.
We also note that Android
Wear adds a browse action.
You'll never find
it on your watch,
but if you're playing
audio, and you
scroll all the way to the
right, you'll find browse.
This allows them to actually
check the next track
or skip multiple tracks or
change playlists and stuff
directly from the watch.
Actually, pretty
useful if you're
one of those kind of people
who hates pulling their giant
X6's out of their pocket.
Now moving to media
browser service
has one thing you'll need to do
call SessionToken in onCreate
and obviously move over from
extending service to extending
media browser service.
Now it also gives you those
new methods onGetRoot,
which is kind of the verifying
what the calling app is.
So if you want Android Auto
to display different data,
you can pass at a different
route from say your own app,
so if you have different
layouts for each one.
And then similar to a
file browser, for example,
onload children gives you
a list of all of the items.
Some of them may be browsable
items, different folders
and subfolders, other ones
might be playable ones.
Similaraly, onload
item just gives you
details about a single item.
So you could see how like you
may be able to build a UI out
of these methods, right?
You may be able to say,
onload children, and get
a list of all the songs
or all of the albums
or all of the most
recently played tracked.
It doesn't really
matter what it is,
but that same list of
tracks can be really done
with onload children, and
then all mode item actually
give you the details
about an individual item.
Now if you want to learn
more about this we actually
have a giant sample app
which does everything
in the world based
on a media browser
a service called Universal
Android Media Player UAMP.
Like I said, currently,
media browser services
is API 21 plus and so is
universal Android Music Player
UAMP.
But I would like to say that
we are working on backporting
both, so we're working
on getting media browser
service to lower API levels as
well as moving over UAMP over
to support a wide
variety of devices.
So you can actually use
all these things much more
even if you're not quite
ready for minSdk 21, anyone?
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, yeah.
All right, great.
Perfect.
You can use it right now.
It's great.
You don't have to
switch any of this.
Now if you're not minSdk
21, then you should be.
But they're really
the best users.
But I understand maybe
that doesn't make sense
for your app.
There are a few other ways other
than using media controller
to get the session
to your activity.
You could do it super
simply use, say,
the EventBus app of your
choice or ex-Java or whatever
or use a static
method in your service
and a local broadcast who'd
say, oh, it's changed.
Super easy to
build, but maybe not
supporting kind of the
multiprocess structure.
Actually, multiprocess is a lot
more important for a media app
because you really want
that background service
to be as low memory, as
low impact as possible
and have your UI not
impact the actual service.
So if your UI crashes
because something's
gone horribly wrong,
you don't necessarily
want that to kill your whole
background playback also.
Another option is to kind of
fake what media browser service
is actually doing under
the covers and bind
to your service,
build an API that
just returns a token for you.
No one really wants
to build this,
but we actually a really good
training on bound services
on developer.android.com
if you're
interested in learning kind
of some of those approaches
to do that.
The simple matter
is it doesn't matter
how you get a token to your UI.
It just matters
that it gets there,
so whatever approach
you want to use now
and then if you want to use
media browser service later,
it's totally possible
and it works great.
So everything that
we've done today
can be summed up in
one slide, probably
should have shown
this at the beginning,
but then you might have left.
But this is the canonical
slide of all the things
you may want to do.
I did note once that the
stopped state, right, if you do
want to keep your service
around for a little bit longer,
you don't necessarily
need to remove everything
as soon as they hit
the stop button.
You may keep it around
a little bit longer.
That's fine, but we've learned
about kind of audio focus
and the noisy broadcast becoming
noisy to really play nicely
with other audio playing apps,
media buttons, lock screens,
and system information,
and media session combat.
And then media
style notifications,
Android Wear support
via media style,
and then media browser
service for Android audio
and building your UI
based on your information.
So feel free to reach out to me
on Google+ Twitter if you have
any questions.
Otherwise, I'll
be right down here
for any questions in the room.
Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]